um i personally want freddy and carly to
be end games but
i'm just like everybody else i don't
know exactly what's gonna happen so
miranda cosgrove it is so good to see
you here across the pond celebrating all
things paramount plus and icarly how are
you feeling how is this for you it's
awesome it's so fun to get to be in
london i haven't been in a few years so
to get to come again and my mom actually
came with me on the trip which is always
fun now how has it been for you stepping
back into
a character
that
was such a huge part of your life
growing up
also your career
yeah it's been crazy because when we
wrapped the original icarly i really
didn't think we were ever gonna visit
these characters again and now it's been
like eight or nine years since we've
finished and it's just it's been so much
fun getting to come back and kind of see
what the character would be like now and
watch her navigate her 20s and go
through a lot of the same stuff that you
know i'm going through with that being
said how was the process then in you
know the writer's room or producing
because you do relate to
where your character's at now so much
how much input did you have
um well it's really fun because i get to
be an executive producer on the show
this time around so the experience has
been really different than when i was 13
and i did the show and i was just trying
to remember the lines and do as good of
a job as i could now i get to do so many
things behind the scenes and that's been
one of the most rewarding parts of
getting to come back just like learning
new skill sets and kind of like building
my confidence in that way what do we
know about another season
well i definitely have my fingers
crossed i hope that we do another um and
we've done two so far so it's kind of
gone by really fast it's kind of been a
whirlwind but yeah it's also crazy
because a lot of the time um so many
things end up happening in real life and
then ending up on the show like even
with the pilot episode of the show it's
all about carly trying to decide if she
wants to start her web show up again for
the first time in 10 years and that was
exactly how i felt in real life
so um it's just funny when things like
that line up with the show what do they
say art imitating life yes definitely
welcome to the new icarly we'll help
however we can i'm really glad to hear
you say that
damn it
what do you think it was about like why
why was now the right time i know
everyone loves nostalgia feeling
you know that certain way of how we felt
the first time we watched the show why
was
now a good time
um i feel like well with cobit and
everything i feel like everybody does
love nostalgia but hopefully it'll be
comforting to people to get to see the
show again and um like for me i love
lizzie mcguire when i was little i'd
back off if i were you unless of course
you want things to get ugly even now
like if i'm at home and
just want to feel good and be happy i'll
watch some old episodes of that show so
um yeah hopefully it'll just be like fun
and it'll make people laugh and feel
good speaking of nostalgia you got to
recreate the interesting meme which
everyone loved on the internet how much
fun did you have with that it was really
fun it's crazy thinking about um how
little i was when a lot of these memes
came to be and you just never know like
what's gonna take on a life of its own
with the internet so um yeah the
internet's constantly humbling me and
it's it's really funny oh we thank you
for the memes
when you look back and you see that
little girl and then you see
now when they're side by side what comes
to mind
um
i don't even know it's just funny
because you know back when i was little
like memes weren't even a thing so it's
just crazy how you never know what's
gonna happen or what things are gonna
catch on and um i try to just kind of
like laugh at all of it and i'm ready
for the next meme to come up
pearl is never going to know me as well
as you do
[Music]
oh pearl i'm sorry
it's okay freddy
you're right
i'm never gonna know you as well as
carly does
because you and carly are clearly in
love with each other
icarly fans have been shipping you to
since the very beginning
what do we have to do to see that happen
um i personally want freddie and carly
to be in the game i think nathan has a
whole theory about this where he thinks
that um freddy tried too hard for too
long and that he doesn't know if they're
meant to be together but um my personal
take is i think that they would be
really good for each other so i'm hoping
that that's how the series ends but
i'm just like everybody else i don't
know exactly what's gonna happen is
there another storyline too that you
would like to see happen um well we
touched on um some stuff with like
getting mean comments online and there's
a whole episode we did in the first
season where carly gets a comment that
says do better and that's all she can
think about
um so it's just always fun when we like
do things like that that are really
relatable like i can totally relate to
that like i'll read comments and i'll
see like 100 nice things and i'll
remember like the one that isn't nice so
um she kind of just drives herself crazy
with this comment and it's like taking
over her life did you want icarly to be
the most successful web series in
history or did you want it to just be
like a massive failure i mean probably
the most successful web series in
history don't i mean it's crazy because
when we started um the series originally
i was 13 and when they came to me and
they said you know it's gonna be the
show about a girl starting a web show i
was like what's a web show like people
aren't gonna know what this is i didn't
really know what it was and now it's
crazy how far the internet has come and
how much it's taken over and everybody
pretty much has a show now online um so
yeah in a way it's exciting because
coming back it gave us a lot more to
work with just because there's so many
more platforms and it's such a like
widely known thing now right um so yeah
it's been fun kind of just seeing where
that character carly would be today and
how she would navigate the craziness of
the internet what's next for you what
were your eyes set on the horizon um i'm
just excited about this revival i hope
that it makes people laugh and that they
enjoy it and um i love to do more of it
i love like working with nathan and
jerry every day and it's been great
getting to see them again i could never
do this show without you
i raised the best woman i know
my sister
[Music]